this here is a screenshot from this
exercise on Khan Academy it says the
number 48 is six times as many as 8
right this comparison as a
multiplication equation so pause this
video and see if you can have a go at
that all right so it sounds very fancy
this comparison is a multiplication
equation but really there's asking us to
write this as an equation and if we were
on Khan Academy we would type it in here
but I'm just going to do it this is a
screenshot so I'm just going to do it by
pen by digital pen so they're saying the
number 48 the number 48 and when they
say is that's another way another way of
interpreting is is to say hey that's
equal to something now what does that
equal to that's equal to 6 times as many
as 8 well what's another way to write 6
times as many as 8 well we could write
that as 6 times 8 so this right over
here this is that comparison written as
a multiplication equation that's all
they're asking for and so you would type
that in right over there let's do
another example here we are told or we
are asked what statement represents the
equation 7 times 4 is equal to 28 so
pause this video and think about which
choice would you pick so let's see
choice a says 28 is 7 more than 4 first
of all that's not true 28 is not 7 more
than 4 but if you were to write this
comparison as an equation this would be
that 28 is so is equal to 7 more than 4
is 7 plus 4 not only is that not true
but that's not the original equation so
we rule that out 28 is 7 times as many
as 4 what is interesting 28 28 is is
equal to 7 times as many as 4 7 times 4
well the only difference between this
and this is just we've swapped the sides
on the Equality which is completely ok
so 28 is equal to 7 times 4 that's the
same equation really as 7 times 4 is
equal to 28 so I like this choice now
let's just look at the other choices 7
is 4
as many as 28 that plays with your head
a little bit but let's just write it as
an equation 7 is so that would be equal
to 4 times as many as 28 that would be 4
times 28 1 this is not true 4 times 28
is over a hundred and so it's not seven
but this is also very different than
what we see up here so we'd rule that
out 7 is 4 less than 28 well this
equation would be 7 is so is equal to 4
less than 28 so for less than 28 would
be 28 minus 4 once again not only is
this not true 28 minus 4 is 24 not seven
but this is not that original equation
so we'd rule that one out as well so we
like our choice be